everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast but the clinical and economic
impact of precision cancer medicine
I'm Robert Castellanos of laborat and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth and sponsored by Intermountain
precision genomics at Intermountain
precision genomics we used a
revolutionary method of gene sequencing
our experts now deliver more precise
medicine than ever before and are on the
forefront of personalized cancer testing
for all types of genetic mutations our
process is unique because we offer a
molecular tumor board review as part of
every test this team approach gives
community oncologists confidence in
providing the best option for patients
drug procurement is also available and
clinical trial information is included
in the results we are providing these
treatments to patients across the nation
giving more people a better quality of
life for more information please visit
Intermountain Healthcare org we have a
few important announcements before we
begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green - a button but the lower
left of the presentation window will try
to answer as many questions as we can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green to an a button
lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of attaining your credits I'd like to
now introduce today's speaker blinken
Nadel dr. Lincoln Madoff MD ph.d is the
executive director of precision medicine
and the precision denominator
Intermountain Healthcare and integrated
healthcare system located in the
Intermountain West
dr. natal completed clinical training in
the medical oncology stem
University School of Medicine where he's
still part of the research faculty
focusing on cancer genomics and
personalized counseling medicine dr.
Nadeau oversees a clinical
implementation of genomic cancer
medicine across Intermountain Healthcare
22 hospitals and under the Navy
physician clinics in a spare time he
enjoys attending his children sports
events water sports fishing and
athletics I'll now turn it over to dr.
Floyd's presentation thank you Robert I
appreciate that kind introduction and I
appreciate the opportunity today to
present our experience at Intermountain
Healthcare with clinically implementing
precision medicine for cancer patients
and I specifically will highlight the
clinical impact that precision medicine
has had on patients as well as the
economic impact so before I start I just
like to highlight the outline of my talk
that will include first reviewing some
of the key principles and challenges in
precision medicine and then I'll
highlight how we establish precision
medicine within an integrated health
delivery system and then highlight the
outcomes that we have seen for patients
and conclude with some of our plans
future steps for those attendees who may
not be familiar with Intermountain
Healthcare this is a an integrated
health delivery network located in Salt
Lake City Utah
best known for implementing best
practices and championing high quality
outcomes referrals are received from a
nationwide reference pool and patients
include those not only living in Utah
but the entire internet West I mentioned
that it's an integrated healthcare
system that consists of approximately
twenty two hospitals in one hundred and
eighty clinics including a children's
hospital care mountain healthcare is an
open system meaning that providers
seeing patients at Intermountain
Healthcare can be employed or they can
be affiliated in addition patients that
are seen at Intermountain Healthcare
don't necessary
we have to have Intermountain health
care insurance or not in health care
accepts all types of insurance so I'd
like to transition now and talk about
some of the primary principles and
challenges associated with precision
medicine many on the webinar may be
familiar that what's outlined here in
this schematic is essentially the the
underlying principle of precision
medicine that includes identifying from
a cancer cell the genomic alterations
that are present and then selecting the
appropriate targeted therapy that would
be used to target that specific genomic
alteration so in any particular
patient's tumor we may find two or three
or four actionable mutations that have
previously been characterized whose
biological relevance is known those
would then be considered known or
clinically actionable variants and could
be targeted with currently available
therapies either through on label use or
off-label use or in some cases through
clinical trials and that's the question
that comes up is it really that simple
it sounds straightforward to say we will
identify the genes and someone's tumor
and then we'll provide them with the
appropriate targeted therapy that
matches that gene of course the
challenge is that nothing's ever quite
as easy as we'd like it to be in some of
the principles that challenge the basic
premise of precision medicine include a
tumor heterogeneity this paper that was
published by Goering uhrin colleagues in
New England Journal of Medicine a few
years ago was an excellent demonstration
of the principle of tumor heterogeneity
they were able to obtain biopsies from
multiple different portions of a renal
cell carcinoma as highlighted in the
cartoon there and then they subsequently
performed the genomic analysis from each
of these different biopsy locations and
found that each different biopsy
location gave a different set of genomic
alterations identified
so that's worrisome from a precision
medicine standpoint because it suggests
that if we obtain tissue and a biopsy
from one portion of a patient's tumor
and identify a list of genomic
alterations that could be targeted with
drugs that may not be the same set of
genomic alteration but implied in a
different part of the tumor so there is
intramural heterogeneity in addition
there is inter tumor heterogeneity so
that different tumors even within the
same individual and may in fact have
different sets of genomic findings as
well and this notion of tumor
heterogeneity is well received and
understood and does present a bit of a
challenge for precision medicine a
second challenge is the concept of tumor
evolution this principle is highlighted
by the phenomenon where tumors may have
an initial set of genomic alterations
that are identified in a patient's tumor
however with the application of
treatment that essentially becomes a
pressure that then selects for clones
that are resistant to that particular
treatment and as highlighting the
schematic we may be able to put a tumor
into remission with certain treatments
only to then have it recur and begin
growing again and if weary biopsy and
perform a genomic analysis we would we
would be able to see that in fact the
new recurrent tumor is comprised of
genomic alterations that are very
distinct and different than the original
tumor that was sequenced and so this
notion of tumor evolution with genomic
alterations constantly changing presents
a challenge and a final challenge
when considering precision medicine is
the sheer number of mutations as I
highlighted on the left in the pediatric
population the number of mutations
identified in any particular tumor is
relatively small for example in a
childhood neuroblastoma we may only find
a dozen mutations
contrastingly in an adult lung cancer
for example non-small-cell lung cancer
we may find up to 150 different
mutations and so there is a wide variety
of mutations we may identify and as the
number grows larger in adult cancers the
ability to interpret the meaning of each
of those mutations and apply the finding
of each mutation to treatment for the
patient becomes increasingly complex
nevertheless the principle of precision
medicine remains and the concept is we
can take a seemingly homogenous
population of patients as represented on
the left in the gray grouping of
patients apply a molecular analysis or
genomic analysis and recognize that in
fact that seemingly homogeneous
population is actually very
heterogeneous and once we recognize the
heterogeneous nature and know what the
molecular makeup of that patient's tumor
is then we can apply the appropriate
targeted therapy in a precision cancer
medicine approach and that's the
approach that we've taken Intermountain
Healthcare we achieved this initially by
establishing a clinical cancer genomics
program patients were referred to our
personalized medicine clinic where they
were provided education and consent
forms regarding the application of
precision medicine ultimately they then
had genomic testing of their tumor this
each genomic test was then reviewed by a
molecular tumor board and ultimately
drug targeted drug was procured and made
available for the patient that's I'm the
program that we initially set up the
workflow that we have established to
accomplish this is outlined in this
slide where patients were initially seen
on day one and then over the next
several days our lab would procure the
sample from whichever pathology lab it
may be located in we perform a review
and prepare the specimen and then
perform this molecular analysis and bio
analytics function and ultimately each
case is reviewed by our molecular tumor
board and then results are delivered and
overall we've now been able to
accomplish that in about a 14 day
turnaround time when we first started we
were closer to 25 or 28 days so we've
gained some significant efficiencies and
being able to turn it around and about
working working days is clinically
impactful for patients and meaningful
for providers this is another way to
think about our workflow from an IT
standpoint on the left-hand side is
highlighted receiving a test order from
a provider and then that goes through a
series of operations that includes a
session inglis specimen generating a run
sheet performing the analysis all the
way down to be generating a report and
delivering that report to the ordering
provider the partners that have helped
us in this include psyops who's provided
the overarching software platform and
we've built this on the background of
Illumina sequencers with analytical and
interpretation input services from a DNA
Nexus in nf1 our molecular tumor board
has been in a very critical aspect of
our implementation of precision medicine
we discovered initially that perhaps the
hardest part and implementing precision
medicine is interpreting genomic results
we found that our community oncologist
colleagues would receive a list of
genomic alterations and very frequently
it would frankly read like Greek finding
a chaos' mutation in a p53 mutation and
then FGFR one alteration and an
amplification of cdk4 is unfamiliar to
most providers so we found that
molecular tumor board interpretation
that ultimately it sent back to the
provider and says here a group of
experts has looked at this and would
suggest targeting variant number one
with drug a and variant number two with
drug B gives the community provider some
confidence in what they're seeing on the
report so we have formed a
multi-institutional molecular tumor
board that is hosted and anchored by
Intermountain Healthcare and then we
invite colleagues from a variety of
organizations and institutions across
the United States including colleagues
from Stanford University and the
Providence Health System and the
University of Colorado and other health
systems and academic organizations
across the country this entire workflow
we built internally at Intermountain
Healthcare and after we began seeing
successful outcomes be resolved to make
it available to providers outside of
Intermountain both nationally and
internationally this is now accomplished
through our website as a not-for-profit
health delivery system we've made this
available through precision cancer org
and any provider can log into this
website order testing and then two weeks
later receive and view interactive test
results that include the molecular
trimmable interpretation and drug
procurement services this is an example
of what one of our reports look looks
like and I wanted to highlight that the
fact that the molecular tumor board
interpretation is included in a report
function in the in the actual report you
can see highlighted in the green box
there where it says molecular tumor
board interpretation is a summary of the
findings and in the case of this example
an EGFR gene mutation was identified and
so the molecular tremor board would say
we suggest targeting EGFR first with
either one of those drugs and then those
drugs could even be ordered by clicking
on the order button and the local
intermountain team would then engage
with that patients insurance provider to
help procure and have the drug shipped
to the to the patient which relieves an
enormous pressure from local community
treating oncologists so we also perform
all of the reporting functions within
the same what web portal our molecular
tumor boards use test reports in this
portal approves them and ultimately
final sign out occurs in this portal and
the results are delivered
through this same web portal as we have
built this program and testing service
in our CLIA and Capp accredited clinical
laboratory we have asked an initial
question we've wondered what kind of
clinical impact does this type of
testing subsequently have on patients we
think that it's terrific to implement
new technology for patients but it's not
in the patient's or provider or payers
best interest if those tests and those
technologies don't in some meaningful
way impact the management of that
patient so the first question we asked
and we're surprised to find that about
half the time a patient's management was
changed upon receipt of the genomic test
result we found that patients are often
changed to receive a different treatment
or I referred to clinical trials so
that's interesting to see some
colleagues in the theatrical setting
have found something similar where they
implemented pol exome sequencing of
pediatric tumors and as published by
Harrison colleagues in JAMA oncology
earlier in 2016 they found that delivery
of genomic testing results also
facilitated a change in management for
those patients approximately 30% of the
time so again a significant change in
management with the addition of genomic
testing which is which suggests that
providers in fact do use this
information the next question we asked
and I highlighted at the beginning that
I would comment on the clinical outcomes
and the economic outcomes and and in
order to evaluate those outcomes for
patients we've set up the study that is
outlined in this slide and for those
that are interested these findings
including the design and setup of this
study was recently published in the
Journal of oncology practice the first
week of September to
sixteen with Haslam its first author for
those who are interested and made all
his last author but what we did was look
at patients who had received you know
testing and were found to have an actual
mutation and we found that and then
received targeted drug and we found
there were 61 patients who fit those
criteria and we wanted to look and see
how many patients also within their
Mountain healthcare system that had not
received genomic testing and a target of
therapy what kinds of outcomes those two
different cohorts had so we match them
up very carefully and the matching
criteria include that patients had to
have the same diagnosis age gender and
number of previous treatment lines in
order to be considered a case in control
match in total when we looked at this we
found 36 patients who had the same age
gender diagnosis and a number of
previous treatments for their cancer as
a control case did so we looked at the
precision medicine cohort of patients
would receive genomic testing and a
targeted therapy compared to the control
cohort of patients who had not received
anomic testing or a targeted therapy but
had gone on to receive the next line of
standard care and then we assess those
patients for both progression-free
survival and the cost of care and we
found that in the precision medicine
cohort there progression-free survival
was approximately 23 weeks whereas in
the control cohort of patients receiving
standard therapy the progression-free
survival was approximately 12 weeks
about half of that so we found a
significant extension of
progression-free survival for patients
who received that genomic analysis and
targeted therapy and the p-value was
highly significant the survival curves
are highlighted in this slide and I
think are significant in the gap that
exists between the targeted therapy
cohort and the standard therapy code
work the next question we asked was
really relative to the cost of care we
wondered how much it cost to implement a
precision medicine approach so we look
at the total costs per patient we look
at the drug cost per patients and we
looked at the total total costs on a per
survival week basis and we found that
the the the primary point here is in
that bottom column we're on a per
survival weaker basis the cost of the
total cost of care including the
positive drug the cost of clinic visits
the cost of any visit to an emergency
room or admission to an inpatient
setting all healthcare associated costs
were 4600 dollars per patient per week
in the precision medicine cohort and
$5,000 per patient per week in the
control cohort and the p-value was not
significant suggesting that while
there's a trend towards it actually
being less expensive to implement a
precision medicine treatment approach at
the very least it does not cost any more
in the costs are essentially equivalent
between those two cohorts whether you
use a standard chemotherapy or
supportive care regimen versus a
precision medicine approach our survival
findings are similar to what was also
recently reported by Roselle Cox group
at UCSD where they performed an enormous
meta-analysis of 300 350 phase one and
Phase two clinical trials where a
precision targeted medicine was matched
to a genomic alteration and over 13,000
patients were evaluated in compared to
patients who received standard therapy
not based on a genomic analysis or
targeted therapy and their findings were
almost identical to what we discovered
in our own cohort which is that the
targeted or precision medicine group had
a progression-free survival of
in seven months which is very close to
the 23 weeks at least ah whereas the
control cohort progression-free survival
was about three months or very close to
the 12 weeks that we saw so that was
very interesting for us to see that
these findings from a large
meta-analysis were very similar to the
findings we had in our cohort of
patients so I think it's interesting and
instructive to talk about cohorts of
patients but I also think that often
providers scientists and others are
interested in individual cases I just
presented you know 70 to total patients
and their collective outcomes but what
about single individuals and I wanted to
just share a slide or two about some
specific patients and how they did
highlighted in this slide is a gentleman
that was part of the cohort that I just
mentioned in our study he is a 56 year
old gentleman who had a an alteration in
a gene called B Roth who was not the
classical v600e mutation commonly seen
in melanoma but nevertheless was an
activating mutation and we were able to
obtain a MEK inhibitor for this patient
in the form of a drug called mechanist
or Amenti nib and after two months he
had a dramatic clinical response as
highlighted in this pest CT scan from
before in the panels on the left where
there is disease outlined by the dashed
yellow line both in the mediastinum as
well as in the supraclavicular region
compared to after 2 months of treatment
where there has been a dramatic response
with shrinkage in both the mediastinum
and the supraclavicular region in total
this patient was able to stay on the
target of therapy before 15 months
before his disease did eventually become
refractory presumably through tumor
evolutionary forces and ultimately the
patient succumbed to disease and passed
away nevertheless he was able to have a
significant and prolonged response when
we otherwise would not have predicted so
for a patient who otherwise had roof
three metastatic lung cancer so that was
an excellent outcome for him we had
another case of the gentleman in his 40s
with advanced colon cancer who had
progressed through multiple treatments
and essentially the entire standard of
care and a genomic analysis identified
an amplification of her two or erbb2 we
wondered about the amplitude of that
amplification and so as something of a
research project we performed a digital
PCR experiment and discovered that in
his tumor the copy number of her 2 was
nearly 30 which is startling and is
really high in fact it's the highest
Hertz and copy number I've ever seen and
it was interesting for us and kind of
exciting because we wondered if this
patient might in fact respond to anti
her to therapy we were able to get in
some anti her to therapy and in this
slide what is highlighted is is the
status of his disease first while on
chemotherapy and as you can see starting
from the left moving to the right those
- dark lesions in the middle of the
liver that are outlined by the dashed
yellow line actually grew bigger while
on chemotherapy then the addition of TDM
one in anti her2 antibody drug conjugate
was applied and these two liver tumors
began to shrink and after three doses in
fact we had a hard time even identifying
them up CT scan this was a very rapid
response occurring after approximately
two months in total the patient was on
the drug for approximately 18 months and
extraordinarily well and his children
were thrilled
unfortunately he too experienced an
evolution of his tumor and it ultimately
became refractory but he did have that
nice prolonged response this is the
final case that I'll share it's a 52
year old woman with advanced melanoma
who had progressed through in a therapy
and didn't have the irassman tation or
other actionable mutations that would
represent an
education for standard therapy but when
we performed this expanded genomic
analysis using our tests that we
developed we found a Cicotte alteration
which can be targeted with a drug called
Gleevec Gleevec or imatinib we were able
to get that drug for the patient and she
again had a very rapid response as
identified by represented by the tumor
on the left encircled by the dashed red
line and three months later it had
shrunk from 8 centimeters down to 2
centimeters as represented in the figure
on the right circled by the dashed red
line this patient ultimately enjoyed a
response for over a year but had disease
in her brain and ultimately she
succumbed but again it did very well I
want to share one final case that
highlights a very important point it's
something that we've discovered as we've
embarked on this precision medicine
approach and it's highlighted by today's
patient with advanced cholangiocarcinoma
she had progressed through multiple
treatments and we found that his tumor
harbored a mutation in a gene called
fgfr2 what was startling is that as we
dug further into his case we found that
in fact he had other cases of this type
of disease and his family and the
pedigree highlighted on this screen
shows that his mother and maternal
grandfather were both affected by
pancreatic cancer and his sister was
diagnosed with cholangiocarcinoma just
like him six weeks after he was
diagnosed with not represented here is
that another brother subject 3-1
subsequently approximately a year after
this patient's diagnosis was diagnosed
with cholangiocarcinoma as well and so
you can quickly see that there is some
indication this might in fact be an
inherited cancer syndrome and and it
turns out that that's what it appears
we've done some additional research and
it appears that that family has an
inherited cancer syndrome I bring that
up
to point out that as we perform these
genomic analyses on a large number of
genes inevitably we identify alterations
in genes that suggest my patients may in
fact have inherited a mutant allele from
a parent so in total for example we have
found two individuals that harbour
germline inherited BRCA mutations one in
breast in one and ovarian then I
mentioned the new familial case of
cholangiocarcinoma and what I'm not
highlighting is we have found some other
inherited forms of melanoma and so the
the principal that is important to keep
in mind is when implementing precision
medicine for cancer patients and
sequencing tumors invariably
we will detect germline alterations and
we must recognize that cancer genomics
do reflect the germline state and so
this slide just represents how that
patient with cholangiocarcinoma
ultimately did we were able to get a
target of therapy for him he had a
prolonged response to an fgfr targeted
therapy and did very well for nearly two
years so that is essentially a summary
of how we have implemented precision
medicine Intermountain Healthcare the
workflow that we've established and the
excellent outcomes that patients have
experienced compared to centered control
treatments for advanced refractory
cancers
I'd like to transition a bit now and for
those that are interested I'm going to
share a little bit of our future plans
including the establishment of a
genomics data sharing consortium a
project that were undertaking with our
biorepository
including the establishment of a
high-throughput sequencing facility and
a recent agreement that we formed with
the Stanford genome Technology Center I
mentioned the genomics data sharing
consortium this is an effort established
by Intermountain Healthcare Providence
Health and services and Stanford
hospitals and clinics and as I spoke
with colleagues about Providence
in Stanford we all quickly came to the
same conclusion that implementing
precision medicine can help patients but
occasionally we identify genomic
variants that are rare and we're unsure
of what to do with those and populations
of patients at a single institution are
in sufficiently large to draw any
conclusions about how to treat those
patients or what outcomes they might
have however we thought if we could
share our data amongst each other then
if I find a patient with an ovarian
cancer for example that has a rare
mutation that I haven't seen before
maybe I won't know how to treat that
patient but if I can see the data and
outcomes from patients at Stanford or
the large cognitive system perhaps
they'll have a patient that had the same
mutation and receive treatment and I'll
know what their outcome was like and
that will make me smarter for treating
my patient so we are now sharing data
between these three institutions and it
includes data points like age and
diagnosis and genomics genomic variants
and treatments etc and the data that is
shared is also the data that you can
view from other institutions this is
called the oncology precision network
it's been a very exciting effort in
addition to these three founding
institutions we have numerous additional
institutions that are joining as we
speak including integrated health
delivery networks across the country and
several academic institutions that are
eager to join in share data so that
their own single institution set of data
can be enlarged by seeing other
institutions data this oncology
precision network was highlighted by
Vice President Biden at his cancer
moonshot event in June at Brown
University the way this works is that as
institutions generate genomic data all
that is consolidated through our science
software platform and is aggregated into
one common database and then we can run
analytics and
ask powerful questions such as show me
all of the patients that have as
represented in this slide as particular
tumor type or maybe I would like to
search the common database by genes or
specific alterations and I can see what
types of treatments those patients had
and so this oncology precision network
or open is becoming a very powerful
resource to understand what types of
alterations exist amongst patients
across the country and what types of
treatments are yielding responses if
there's anyone on the webinar that would
be interested in learning more or even
possibly contributing data to the
oncology precision network please don't
hesitate to reach out to me directly and
I can help answer any questions I'll
transition now to a second project that
we are working on the Intermountain
Healthcare biorepository consists of
approximately 4 million clinical
specimens that have been collected since
1975 these samples are archived in FFPE
blocks over the last 40 years
and what's extraordinarily unusual about
these is that we have clinical digital
and searchable outcomes in our
electronic data warehouse over about 30
years what that practically means is I
can walk into the bio repository and
pictured there on the slide is an actual
picture of our by repository I can open
one of those boxes pull out a shelf pull
a specimen out of it and then I could go
into the electronic data warehouse and
find all of the digital outcomes
associated with that specimen over a
30-year period represents an
extraordinarily powerful opportunity to
ask important questions in order to
unlock the secrets hidden away in those
specimens from the last 40 years we are
building a high-throughput sequencing
facility on the platform of an x10
Illumina HiSeq instrument that will
allow us the capacity to do up to
10,000 genomes a year and it will enable
the sequencing of our by repository for
novel discovery and as we take those
genomic alterations and combine them
with the clinical outcomes for each
sample we'll be able to discover for
example the molecular fingerprint that
may predict for recurrence in colon
cancer for predictors of response to
certain treatments in breast cancer and
on and on the list of possibilities and
questions goes finely and in conclusion
we have begun to recognize that one of
our great strengths is the delivery of
medicine in the clinical setting to
become increasingly excellent in that
pursuit we have recognized the need to
develop new and adapt novel technologies
in order to accomplish that we have
recently formed a partnership with the
Stanford genome technology Center where
we will be jointly developing
technologies that have particular
clinical application and then clinically
implementing those including molecular
diagnostics wearable sensor devices and
others so in summary what we have found
in our efforts at Intermountain
Healthcare and our precision medicine
program is that in fact precision cancer
medicine is feasible and you know as we
applied it we found that there is
actually an improved progression-free
survival and so this is significant for
patients it represents another treatment
option for providers and patients alike
sort of when patients become refractory
or if they are not candidates for
standard therapy or sending therapy
hasn't worked that providing a precision
medicine approach remains an outstanding
and viable option for them additional
clinical trials are currently underway
including the National Cancer Institute
match trial and the taper trial
sponsored by ASCO both of which are
evaluating the use of precision targeted
therapies based on genomic test
results to determine whether precision
cancer medicine is indeed associated
with superior outcomes as the UCSD study
has identified in our study as well
additional summary points from our
experience include that healthcare
associated costs for precision medicine
patients is not higher than standard
chemotherapy approaches we've also found
the pediatric tumors higher hide harbor
high numbers clinically actionable
variants and finally that the somatic
sequence sequencing of forced somatic
alterations invariably identify these
germline alterations so I would just
like to pause and acknowledge the very
big team comprised of standing and
capable individuals who have made all of
this work possible and that includes the
list of individuals there from our inner
mount precision genomics team as well as
colleagues from Stanford University some
funding has come from the NCI and from
ASCO for which we are grateful and with
that I think we have a few minutes left
to take some questions and I'd be happy
to answer some questions thank you well
thank you so very much doctor for that
amazing and informative presentation
before we get started on our
question-and-answer session I like to
remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left at the
presentation window and again we're
going to try to answer as many questions
as we possibly can our first question is
is it practical to have molecular board
to review each report and how often does
the military board need to do this so
that is an outstanding question having a
live molecular tumor board review every
single case is very powerful but as the
questioner points out it's also not
scalable it quickly becomes a bottleneck
as volumes increase and we've actually
already begun to experience that
so in the short-term we're overcoming
this bottleneck and scaling challenge by
increasing the numbers of members of our
molecular tumor board so that we can
meet more frequently and currently we're
meeting twice weekly to review all the
cases and we're able to keep up with the
volumes that way in the long run we are
leveraging artificial intelligence and
machine learning algorithms to learn
from what our past molecular tumor board
interpretations have suggested and then
apply that to the future so excellent
question we recognize the impracticality
z' of a live molecular tumor board as
volume scale to thousands or tens of
thousands of patients and we have
solutions that are in the works that we
anticipate will be successful thank you
for the question and our next question
is how do you address the intra tumor
heterogeneity and in your analysis it's
an excellent question and we view
intramural heterogeneity as an
opportunity for patients so we obtain a
biopsy of a tumor like everyone and we
perform the sequencing and if we
identify an actual mutation and we'll
provide targeted therapy based on that
actual mutation or set of mutations then
if the patient ultimately becomes
refractory after a period of time then
we often will repeat the biopsy knowing
that either tumor evolution has yielded
new alterations or biopsy from that same
tumor but in a slightly different
location may yield other actual
mutations that we can target with
different drugs so we don't believe it's
possible to address every single
alteration harbored in every tumor from
the outset however by taking different
biopsies at different points in time you
can in fact identify different Actimel
mutations that add to the list of
treatment options for that particular
patient great question
and have you examined any disparities in
access to precision cancer medicine and
more SES populations and Medicare
patients we haven't yet discovered on
geographical disparities in access to
drug but there are disparities amongst
different payers some pairs more readily
approved
targeted therapies based on precision
genomic testing whereas other payers are
very slow or frankly reject those
requests and we have to go through an
appeals process we've also found that
payers are I think becoming increasingly
educated and understanding of this
approach and we're seeing increasingly
frequent approvals for therapies which
is encouraging so that's a great
question I'm glad that was asked and are
you exploring liquid biopsies in
addition to solid tumor biopsy liquid
biopsy is an exciting and potentially
transformative technology in cancer we
like others are exploring the
applications of liquid biopsy we're
doing that in the research setting
currently with patient samples and are
evaluating the application and the
appropriate applications some of the
immediate applications that are most
obvious that our patients will begin
experiencing very soon include liquid
biopsies for monitoring response to
therapy we are finding that tracking the
abundance of certain alterations in the
circulating tumor DNA fraction of course
lends to response to treatment and as we
verify that's true we'll be able to
delay for CT scanning for example if we
see that a patient is responding based
on declining fractions of molecular
variants in the peripheral blood then we
can have confidence in delaying CT scan
because we know they're doing well or
responding additional applications for
liquid biopsy that we're exploring and
others are aware of this as well include
the use of liquid biopsies for
monitoring and surveillance so if a
patient is in remission for example can
we use liquid biopsy to monitor for
disease recurrence and then ultimately
we anticipate being able to use liquid
biopsy to in undiagnosed patients so to
diagnose disease that earlier and
earlier stages of of disease which is
exciting and perhaps the most
revolutionary application of liquid
biopsy technology great question
our next question is somatic alterations
was like some germline alterations by
germline do you mean heredity yeah great
question of course the tumor has or
harbors alterations that have occurred
somatically meaning you know at some
point during the patient's life and by
germline exactly as the questioner
proposed I'm referencing inherited DNA
so the germline DNA is what I mean by
that is the the copies of the
chromosomes and genes that patient may
have inherited from their parents and
has been present with them from birth
and is also the same DNA they would pass
on to their children for example good
question come on next question here is
some cancers are caused by viruses would
that be detected by genetic analysis
yeah you know this this is an astute
question that's a great question
there are some cancers that are caused
by viruses what an example would be
cervical cancer and human papillomavirus
HPV is also considered the causative
agent in some forms of head and neck
cancer and in fact these two examples
are the exact reason there's a strong
push now for HPV vaccinations in
children of certain ages
but we're finding that some of these
virally driven cancers respond extremely
well to certain treatments those can be
the virally driven cancers can sometimes
be identified by economic analysis many
of the genomic tests that are on the
market now interrogate a panel of genes
the inter-mountain precision genomics
ICG 100 tests and is an example of that
where we test a panel of genes testing a
panel of genes doesn't necessarily
detect inserted genomic DNA and nor do
other similar tests that are on the
market so I guess the short answer is
sometimes we can identify virally driven
tumors based on genomic analysis but not
every time right here a next question is
despite many cutting-edge technologies
why do people still die of cancers is it
probable or possible that environmental
factors distribute or disrupt early
diagnostics and treatment yeah great
question undoubtedly
there are environmental factors that
play significant roles in cancer not
only in their cause but in delaying
their diagnosis you know the best
examples of the causative environmental
factors of course include cigarette
smoking and you know exposure repeated
in prolonged sun exposure contributing
to melanoma and other hazardous
environmental agents contributing to
bladder cancers and other cancers in
terms of whether environmental agents
directly lead to delayed diagnosis it's
difficult to determine but it's clear
that our precision medicine technologies
are exciting and yielding new treatment
options but just as the questioner
pointed out they are not necessarily
resulting in new cures that we weren't
seeing before to date we've primarily
used precision medicine approaches
in patients with advanced or refractory
cancers and while we're seeing a
prolongation of life in those patients
we're not seeing cures and what we think
that means is we might be on the verge
of turning cancer into a chronic disease
which would be excellent for patients
given that in the past patients
diagnosed with cancer too frequently
have had their disease advanced and take
their lives in a matter of months and if
we could change that narrative so that
patients are living years or decades
with their disease that would be
exciting that's of course what we've
seen with diabetes or heart disease we
don't necessarily care patients of their
diabetes we don't cure patients of their
heart disease but we have treatments in
place where they can live normal lives
for prolonged periods with it with their
chronic conditions good question
thank you very much doctor and what
patient population do you treat i myself
have been treating patients with
advanced refractory cancer is looking
for just as i've been talking about in
this presentation looking for genomic
actionable alterations and providing
targeted therapies historically my focus
has been patients with gastrointestinal
malignancies path Intermountain and
healthcare
we've been treating all facets of
patients we've primarily focused our
precision medicine efforts on patients
with solid tumors but we treat patients
with both solid and liquid tumors
included including what follows Keith
good question all right here it looks
like a final question that we have time
for today is a rule patients insurance
cover the cost of genomic testing we
have found that insurance is covering
this and different payers cover at
different levels and different rates
our approach Intermountain Healthcare as
our not-for-profit organization has been
to work directly with payers so that
patients are not experiencing
out-of-pocket expenses and that's been
very successful and we're probably
we don't have patients experiencing
out-of-pocket expenses when this type of
testing is performed we anticipate that
this will continue to be the case and
we're excited that we are able to offer
that to patients thank you and do you
have any closing remarks for today's
presentation well I appreciate the
opportunity and for those who tuned in
thank you I know that everyone has busy
schedules and I appreciate the
opportunity to share with others
the experience that we've had is we've
tried to help patients by taking novel
and innovative approaches to treating
cancer our hope is that in the future
we'll continue to find cancer treatments
that are effective and yield prolong
survivals and maybe cures while not
increasing the cost of health care in
this country so I appreciate the
opportunity to present thank you for
your attention
I thank you and I like to thank the
doctor again for his wonderful
presentation I also like to thank the
audience for your outstanding questions
I'd also like to thank our sponsors
Intermountain precision genomics for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
January of 2017 you'll receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye